so how much of solving intelligence this
big goal for deepmind how much of it is
science how much is engineering so how
much is the algorithms how much is the
data how much is the
hardware compute infrastructure
how much is it the software computer
infrastructure yeah um what else is
there how much is the human
infrastructure
and like just the humans interact in
certain kinds of ways in all the space
of all those ideas how much is maybe
like philosophy how much what's the key
if um
uh
if if you were to sort of look back like
if we go forward 200 years look back
what was the key thing that solved
intelligence is there ideas
i think it's a combination first of all
of course it's a combination of all
those things but the the ratios of them
changed over over time
so yeah so um even in the last 12 years
so we started deep mine in 2010 which is
hard to imagine now because 2010 it's
only 12 short years ago but nobody was
talking about ai uh you know if you
remember back to your mit days you know
no one was talking about it i did a
postdoc at mit back around then and it
was sort of thought of as a well look we
know ai doesn't work we tried this hard
in the 90s at places like mit mostly
losing using logic systems and
old-fashioned sort of good old-fashioned
ai we would call it now um people like
minsky and and and patrick winston and
you know all these characters right and
used to debate a few of them and they
used to think i was mad thinking about
that some new advance could be done with
learning systems and um i was actually
pleased to hear that because at least
you know you're on a unique track at
that point right even if every all of
your you know professors are telling you
you're mad that's true and of course in
industry uh you couldn't we couldn't get
you know as difficult to get two cents
together uh and which is hard to imagine
now as well given it's the biggest sort
of buzzword in in vcs and and
fundraising's easy and all these kind of
things today so
back in 2010 it was very difficult and
what we the reason we started then and
shane and i used to discuss um uh uh
what were the sort of founding tenets of
deep mind and it was very various things
one was um algorithmic advances so deep
learning you know jeff hinton and cara
just had just sort of invented that in
academia but no one in industry knew
about it uh we love reinforcement
learning we thought that could be scaled
up but also understanding about the
human brain had advanced um quite a lot
uh in the in the decade prior with fmri
machines and other things so we could
get some good hints about architectures
and algorithms and and and sort of um
representations maybe that the brain
uses so as at a systems level not at a
implementation level um and then the
other big things were compute and gpus
right so we could see uh a compute was
going to be really useful and it got to
a place where it become commoditized
mostly through the games industry and
and that could be taken advantage of and
then the final thing was also
mathematical and theoretical definitions
of intelligence so things like ai xi aix
which uh shane worked on with his
supervisor marcus hutter which is a sort
of theoretical uh proof really of
universal intelligence
which is actually a reinforcement
learning system
um in the limit i mean it assumes
infinite compute and infinite memory in
the way you know like a turing machine
proves but i was also waiting to see
something like that too to you know like
turing machines uh and and computation
theory that people like turing and
shannon came up with underpins modern
computer science um uh you know i was
waiting for a theory like that to sort
of underpin agi research so when i you
know met shane and saw he was working on
something like that you know that to me
was a sort of final piece of the jigsaw
so
in the early days i would say that uh
ideas were the most important uh you
know for us it was deep reinforcement
learning scaling up deep learning um of
course we've seen transformers so huge
leaps i would say you know three or four
from for if you think from 2010 till now
uh huge evolutions things like alphago
um and um and and maybe there's a few
more still needed but as we get closer
to ai agi um i think engineering becomes
more important and data because scale
and of course the the recent you know
results of gpt3 and all the big language
models and large models including our
ones uh has shown that scale is a is and
large models are clearly going to be a
necessary but perhaps not sufficient
part of an agi solution and
throughout that like you said and i'd
like to give you a big thank you you're
one of the pioneers in this is
sticking by ideas like reinforcement
learning that this can actually work
given actually
limited success in the past
and also
which we still don't know but
proudly having the best researchers in
the world and talking about solving
intelligence so talking about whatever
you call it agi or something like this
that speaking of mit that's that's just
something not you wouldn't bring up no
not not maybe you did in uh like 40 50
years ago
but that was
um
ai was a place where you do tinkering
very small scale not very ambitious
projects and
uh
maybe the biggest ambitious projects
were in the space of robotics and doing
like the darpa challenge sure but the
task of solving intelligence and
believing you can that's really really
powerful so
in order for engineering to do its work
to have great engineers
build great systems you have to have
that belief that threats throughout the
whole thing that you can actually solve
some of these impossible challenges yeah
that's right and and back in 2010 you
know our mission statement um and still
is today you know it was used to be uh
solving step one solve intelligence step
two use it to solve everything else yes
so if you can imagine pitching that to a
vc in 2010 you know the kind of looks we
we got we managed to you know find a few
uh kooky people to back us but it was uh
it was tricky and and i and i got to the
point where we we wouldn't mention it to
any of our professors because they would
just eye roll and think we you know
committed career suicide and and uh and
and you know so it was there's a lot of
things that we had to do but we always
believed it and one reason you know by
the way one reason we i believe i've
always believed in reinforcement
learning is that
that if you look at neuroscience that is
the way that the you know primary brain
learns one of the main mechanisms is the
dopamine system implements some form of
td learning a very famous result in the
late 90s uh where they saw this in
monkeys and uh and as a you know proper
game prediction error so we you know
again in the limit this is this is what
i think you can use neuroscience for is
is you know any at mathematics you when
you're when you're doing something as
ambitious as trying to solve
intelligence and you're you're you know
it's blue sky research no one knows how
to do it you you you need to use any
evidence or any sort of information you
can to help guide you in the right
direction or give you confidence you're
going in the right direction so so that
that was one reason we pushed so hard on
that and that's and just going back to
your early question about organization
the other big thing that i think we
innovated with at deepmind to encourage
uh invention and and uh and innovation
was the multidisciplinary organization
we built and we still have today so
deepmind originally was a confluence of
the of the most cutting-edge knowledge
in neuroscience
with machine learning engineering and
mathematics right and and gaming uh and
then since then we built that out even
further so we have philosophers here and
and uh by you know ethicists but also
other types of scientists physicists and
so on um and that's what brings together
i tried to build a sort of um new type
of bell labs but in his golden era right
uh uh and and a new expression of that
um to try and uh foster this incredible
sort of innovation machine so you're
talking about the humans in the machine
the mind itself is a learning machine
with a lot of amazing human minds in it
coming together to try and build these
learning systems
you